Xbox has finally announced the first
wave of its Game Pass lineup for April
it's also revealed that while its own
exclusive Quantum break that were
released in 2016 has been taken off the
service it's only temporary while the
company and developer remedy sort out
some licensing issues for anyone that
was a fan of remedy's follow-up game
control Quantum break is a pretty cool
somewhat similar experience that also
happens to Star the late great Lance
Reddick available starting today on Game
Pass making its console debut is Loop
hero an excellent indie game that puts
you in control of the Apocalypse
surrounding its main character rather
than the other way around building on
top of the procedurally generated path
they walk and placing enemies and
environmental elements to build up their
strength and skills it's incredibly
unique and well worth checking out if
you're a subscriber on April 6th and
12th come iron Brigade and ghost wire
Tokyo the last to being a Bethesda title
that was tied up in contracts with
PlayStation before the company's
acquisition by Microsoft it has been a
console exclusive on PS5 for a year but
Xbox players can finally get the taste
of the first person ghostbusting action
as well as the spider's threat update
which will be new to the game then on
April 13th and 18th Last Falls NHL 23
and the new title Minecraft Legends will
drop the latter is a full RPG experience
set in the Minecraft Universe and the
former is ice hockey enough said NHL 23
comes as a part of EA play which game
pass ultimate subscribers have access to
and also means those top tier Subs
currently have access to a 10 hour early
trial of EA's latest PGA Tour title as
well this is a big day for fans of some
of the US's least popular sports also
coming in April is OverWatch 2's newest
hero life Weaver on the 11th players
will be able to take advantage of this
new support class character while
previous new characters such as ramatra
have required the purchase of a premium
battle pass for an immediate unlock
things are a little different with life
Weaver lifeweaver will be available for
free for a limited time when he drops
into the game how long that limited time
is we don't currently know but he will
eventually be free for anyone that
reaches tier 55 on the battle pass you
will also be a part of an in-game event
on April 24th to coincide with the Thai
New Year Thailand being the character's
home lifeweaver's abilities fuse bio
light with plant life his primary
abilities are healing Blossom and Thorn
volley the former allows him to charge
up a luminescent flower that he can send
out to heal allies the longer he charges
the more healing it does the latter has
life Weaver shooting out by a light
thorns in a scattered pattern so he
sounds like yet another support hero in
the game that can deal a decent amount
of damage he also has Pebble platform
which any hero Ally or enemy can use to
levitate in the air as well as
rejuvenating Dash which allows life
Weaver to Dash and rejuvenate life grip
is a move that allows the support
character to pull allies toward him
making them invulnerable while doing so
and pulling them out of Harm's Way
finally life Weaver's ultimate is Tree
of Life which not only creates cover for
his team but can heal nearby allies but
there's even more stuff to do in April
Pokemon Stadium the Pokemon's franchise
first ever jumped from portable to
home-based consoles is coming to the
Nintendo switch Online Library of N64
games on April 12th Pokemon Stadium lets
players Babble in both single player
challenges like the gym leader castle
and multiplayer modes like the minigame
focused kids club the game features all
151 Pokemon from the red blue yellow era
as well as trainers from the inaugural
Pokemon Adventure I want to personally
thank Nintendo for finally giving this a
release date because ever since they
announced its Edition last last year my
girlfriend has asked me pretty much
every day since when it was coming so
yeah I really appreciate it well Game
Pass games are you checking out this
month what do you think of the new
OverWatch character life Weaver and are
you going to play Pokemon Stadium on
Nintendo switch let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you here
for more Gamespot news
[Music]